le centre culturel islamique de québec
où a eu lieu l'attentât terroriste de
dimanche soir avait été la cible d'un
geste à caractère haineux l'été dernier
une tête de porc déposés devant l'une de
ses portes et ce en pleine période du
ramadan les trains qui slame aux femmes
avaient également été distribués à
différents endroits de la ville de
québec dans les semaines suivant cet
incident comment croire que dans
générosité un milieu de ces grands
enjeux planétaires une telle amir khadir
née à téhéran est un physicien de
formation un médecin spécialisé et un
homme politique québécois membres du
parti politique de gauche québec
solidaire
hier soir ce député provincial québécois
sautait à cette conclusion
je crois que quand on a la tête de la
plus grande puissance du monde
non qu'ils s'emploient à propager la
haine et indices plié ce genre de
ressentiment à l'égard des musulmans à
l'égard des étrangers à logements ce
genre de choses arrive alors je tiens
monsieur trompe en partie responsable de
ces dérives la base de ces comportements
existe partout dans le monde mais c'est
sûr qu'à partir du moment où l'homme le
plus puissant de la terre depuis son
entrée en fonctions ne cesse d'alimenter
une atmosphère générale de ressentiment
envers l'étranger sa conscience juste
raimu les musulmans on comprend bien qu
aux etats unis aussi des mexicains mais
fait de sa politique populiste
une politique de ressentiment et de deux
de méfiance à l'endroit de tout ce qui
est étranger
c'est sûr que ces responsables ont une
responsabilité sur les réseaux sociaux
ont réagi notamment un auditeur qui
écrit donald trump n'a absolument rien à
voir avec les attentats les seuls
responsables sont les terroristes
il faut arrêter de toujours accusé d
autres et se remettre à un moment donné
en question si l'islamophobie avait bien
joué un rôle ici dans cette tragédie
quelle sera leur impact sur image de
nous-mêmes sur notre vision de
l'inclusion et aussi sur nos canadiens
de religion musulmane une augmentation
importante
à l'égard des communautés musulmanes qui
vivent au québec et ça cette
augmentation s'est particulièrement dans
les médias sociaux sous forme de vidéos
et de phrases la députée québécoise du
parti québec solidaire a tenté de faire
adopter une motion contre l'islamophobie
au québec jean catalogue sur mon bureau
de toutes les horreurs qui peuvent se
dire s'est créé et qui peuvent se
montrer en vidéo sur les médias sociaux
ça n'a vraiment aucun sens et ça me
rappelle les pires moments des débats
d'il ya deux ans le sur la charte des
valeurs par exemple monsieur qui dit
les arabes ne connaissent pas l'amour la
femme est un objet pour eux un autre
c'est peau dure les arabes sont des
manipulateurs invétéré pour une femme et
je suis une esclave et solo ça se
continue ça continue
et toute cette idée profondément ancrée
chez certaines personnes que parce que
deux femmes 1 4 1 qui ont voulu voter le
visage couvert au fédéral lors toutes
les femmes vont devenir voile est avant
tout portée niqab on réfère de toutes
les classes
il ya une espèce de surenchère qui
extrêmement alterne concept de la
laïcité très souvent mal compris il ya
des gens qui en font un instrument de
l'islamophobie et pilou évidemment bats
contre ça
haroun bouazzi et co fondateur et
président de l'association des musulmans
et des arabes pour la laïcité au québec
on se bat pour la liberté de conscience
pour une véritable neutralité de l'état
c'est à dire que les gens soient pas
avantager ou désavantagé par leur
religion et puis pour une séparation des
institutions religieuses des
institutions de l'état et ça pour nous
ça veut pas dire qu'on met à la porte à
mes temps parce qu'il ya une kippa sur
la tête ou une enseignante parce qu'elle
a décidé de mettre un foulard sur la
tête
c est à ce moment là on est vu comme
comme des traîtres par des groupes
islamophobes qui évidemment voudrait
garder la laïcité comme étant un outil
qui permette de mettre à la porte ou
d'exclure des minorités religieuses des
institutions de l'état
l'islamophobie sonatel plus répandu
qu'on n'ose l'avouer la chroniqueuse de
radio canada marie ève tremblay a crié
deux identités martin delorme et
mohammed habouch d'ide et elle a répondu
en leur nom à une cinquantaine d'offres
de location de logements dans les
journaux de montréal
résultat la personne qui a un nom
québécois et 40 % plus susceptibles
d'obtenir un rendez-vous
j'ai envoyé plusieurs dizaines de
requêtes pour visiter des logements sur
kijiji et je les fais en utilisant un
nom d'origine québécoise est un nom
d'origine arabe
j'ai créé deux personnalités fictive les
courriels envoyés par chacun 10 est
sensiblement la même chose il était bien
écrit très polis convivial et pour
éviter toute interprétation possible
j'ai envoyé les courriels du nom arabe
avant ceux du non québécois j'ai donné
cinq jours aux propriétaires pour
répondre j'ai envoyé des courriels aux
50 premières annonces affichées les 50
premières que je voyais en tout 44
propriétaires ont répondu à au moins un
des deux locataires potentiels 42 ont
invité martin à visiter leur logement
seulement 30 ont invité mohamed à
visiter leur logement c'est pas étonnant
étant dans tout ce qu'on savait déjà au
niveau des discriminations à l'embauché
que ce soit la même chose au niveau du
logement aussi émilie nicolas et
président de l'organisme québec inclusif
elle n'est pas surprise d'apprendre que
les personnes avec un nom à consonance
arabe en 40 % moins de chances de
trouver un appartement que quelqu'un qui
a un nom québécois il y avait une étude
qui a été faite il quelques années par
la com soudain droits de la personne qui
disait que maintenant les trucs qu'on a
que vous venez pas avec le reportage
chez 40% de chances de moins pour pour
le mohamed que pour le martin je sais
trop bien pour la discrimation
d'embaucher 60 % moins de chances de se
faire rappeler quand on s'appelait
traoré ou ben msâad touquet constate
l'étrangler l'automne dernier le canada
a condamné officiellement l'islamophobie
l'afer a trouvé peu d'écho dans les
grands médias canadiens mais cette
motion par des parlementaires pour
contrer l'islamophobie qui a été adoptée
à l'unanimité serait selon la porte
parole du forum musulman canadien
sama djebbari une première mondiale un
reportage de radio canada international